en las últimas horas han aumentado
enormemente los ataques aquí en Ucrania
según las autoridades locales se han
producido 170 ataques en particular en
el este y en el sur del país uno de los
peores ha sido en la ciudad de saporilla
así han fallecido al menos tres personas
hay otros que están bajo los escombros y
hay decenas de heridos según han
informados las autoridades locales más
ataques han ocurrido también en la
región de nipro recordemos que se trata
de una región estratégica y importante
pues es un Hub de distribución militar y
también de ayuda humanitaria y también
continúan la batalla de bajo mutua donde
el presidente ucraniano ha dicho que en
las próximas horas serán enviados más
refuerzos para resistir a la ofensiva
rusa que continúa desde hace semanas en
el intento de tomar esta estratégica
ciudad y también en el frente
diplomático aquí en Ucrania se ha estado
muy pendiente de las palabras del
canciller alemán que ha dicho en las
últimas horas a China de que no envíe
armas a Rusia sino que use su influencia
para que
Moscú retire las tropas de este país en
otro apartado
Moscú ha afirmado que occidente ha
enterrado el acuerdo del grano
recordemos que este acuerdo es el
acuerdo que permitió el desbloqueo de
los cereales que se encontraban en los
puertos ucranianos los que también frenó
la hambruna en el mundo y pues este
acuerdo en los próximos días se debería
volver a discutir pues caduca Y si la
parte no lo renovarán Entonces se tendrá
que suspender estas exportaciones y
distribuciones de grano en el mundo